the jurogan experience bread used to
just be food
when the [ __ ] did bread become bad for
you
evil [ __ ]
you know there's the conspiracy theory
that um that it's glyphosate that's
[ __ ] people up
that it's not um
what see what that is all about because
i've heard people talk about that what
is it like uh like i think robert
kennedy jr was talking about that
he was talking about glyphosate
glyphosate is roundup roundup is that
stuff that they spray wow yeah no that's
the stuff's supe super bad for you right
there's no way there's roundup
but hold on if they use it on these
plants
where does it go how do they wash it off
like what kind of residual effect does
that stuff have sure on the food you eat
or plastics can you imagine if that was
what was going on
and that's why like european people
don't look like us oh yeah more than
half the products tech oh [ __ ] wow more
than half the products tested had
detectable levels of glyphosate above 10
parts per billion 45 out of 86 products
contained detectable levels of
glyphosate ranges were from 12 parts per
billion to 1 150 parts per billion
organic foods are much less likely to
have trace amounts of glyphosate however
it is appearing in low levels in some
cases
it's crazy
damn they they got you perfect that was
nice
the pop-up was the timed pop-ups
yeah so uh yeah so there's glyphosate in
foods it gets trace amounts of
glyphosate that's insane
glyphosate in popular
bread oats legumes protein powders and
bars 20 22. holy [ __ ] that's everything
you have very easy you know you have the
protein powers dude
all that stuff yeah how wild is that
because it's like
it's a really common chemical that's
used and it's really bad for you and if
that's it
i mean that i don't i don't know i mean
is there a kind of organic wheat that
you know is 100 glyphosate free
and if you ate that would you feel
different
i bet there is i bet or is these are
these trace amounts of glyphosate that
aren't really affecting you
like i wish i knew
i mean like what it sounds scary when
they're talking about parts per billion
but i wish like a scientist would go
well
not a lot right it's like those
microplastics when i start reading about
microplastics and stuff like that i
start freaking out do you know how much
we eat every week yeah it's nuts it's a
credit card yeah we need a credit card
craziness i wish i could remember i
i read someone said that it's not a
misinterpretation but
that's like the highest end it could be
as a credit card i think when they saw
somebody who eats microwave and they
even like the way they got that number
was like studying clams or something
like that and then did uh a next uh
a math problem i can't think of the word
right now to figure out what it would be
like in humans if it was the same size
oh
that's how they so there's a little
[ __ ] there's a lot a little all of it
i don't know but there is some so like a
little bit of [ __ ] true but it seemed
like there was a little bit of a like uh
okay yeah it's well credit card seems
like a lot
and how much stays in your body and how
much do you [ __ ] out right i bet you'd
[ __ ] a lot of it out
what like 99.9 probably
but what if you don't yeah
you know
plastics and stuff in your body
see here's like the article but like for
weirdly it starts off saying globally we
are ingesting an average of five grams
so it's an average too
and that we're just globally right
globally like maybe some parts of the
world are higher yeah like us
i think we'd be pretty high yeah if
you're getting it from like microwaving
food with plastic on it we got to be
high as [ __ ] yeah we've been doing that
for a long time
and plastic forks and there's little
plastic containers your food comes in to
go boxes there's always like little
pieces of plastic somewhere i guarantee
you even this article says it's just
australians it says australian suggested
credit card not everyone so i don't know
well is that an article from australia
well an australian analysis says that um
interesting can you really trust those
australian analysis can anymore
yeah i uh i'm worried though well i'm
worried also because i had that dr
shanna swan lady on the podcast who
talked about uh
what plastics and these chemicals like
phthalates are doing to the reproductive
systems of people
did do you ever hear about that yeah
obviously i i think i heard about it
from she's got this book called
countdown and it's all about what um
plastics are doing to people's
reproductive systems right yeah my
girlfriend
is obsessed with that all that [ __ ] and
she thinks we're dying from it well
we're changing
we're changing this is the the problem
as it's met it's dropped men's sperm
counts 50 lower than they were in like
the 1950s
um
women have more miscarriages
and men's taints are shrinking
that's a good thing no no
i want my [ __ ] right next to my dick
masturbate you just put your finger in
there
you know
like pick it up like a bowling
ball um that's bad because the closer
the taints are it's the more feminizing
of the male this is what it is like in
mammals and i'll probably [ __ ] this up
my apologies in advance in mammals
male taints are between 50 and 100
percent larger than the females
so that's one of the best ways that they
detect whether or not an a mammal like a
like a puppy is a boy or girl
the taint is bigger
but in men uh over the last x amount of
years they've been shrinking
and they've been shrinking steadily
which is an indication of penis sizes
are shrinking testicles are shrinking
sperm counts dropping like 50 percent
lower and at the same time this is the
introduction of petrochemical products
like plastics and stuff like that and
eating out of plastic bottles and
drinking out of plastic bottles eating
out of plastic plates
like that all this stuff has entered
into the bloodstreams and they've found
in studies in mammals
that when they introduce these
phthalates to mammals
their offspring are affected the
reproductive systems are affected
it's wild [ __ ] dude because it's like
we're we're doing something weird to the
human organism
and we're doing it through plastics and
we're just now finding out about it like
we're only finding out about this over
the last i think
we talked about this i always forget i
want to say like 2015 right
it was not that long ago that they they
discovered this
nuts so she wrote this whole book about
it and she's a really funny lady too
she's got like a thing on her instagram
called the jizz quiz
and it's all about you know like
a quiz on like how much men's sperm
counts have dropped over the last 50
years and it's like
it's so weird it's wild because it's
just we're
it's unavoidable
like we're just
accustomed to consuming a certain amount
of plastics and having plastic chemicals
in our body
how's the connection of that done is it
could it be something else like you know
they're really sure that phthalates do
that
and phthalates are some of the chemicals
that you get from like you know plastics
and i think some pesticides affect the
body in a similar way there's like a lot
of [ __ ] that we encounter that [ __ ]
with reproductive systems
so when they did it
with animal studies when they did it
they sho it showed that the males
all came out like more feminine and with
smaller taints and the whole deal
and it's all about how many uh you know
what what what kind of chemicals the
mother has in her body when she
conceives
it's wild stuff man because it's like
the implications are if we don't stop
using them
we're going to change the species
over plastic like it'll change what it
means to be a male human
because it won't be like a male human
used to be before plastics it's crazy
if that really imagine if it's like
unavoidable you can't get it out of of
humans and it's just gonna keep
feminizing males and and turning their
taints into smaller and smaller little
patches of land well then finally we it
doesn't matter you know we could have
guys and girls play the same sports
together right
one day one day
maybe that's where we're headed yeah
maybe it's already started